[Musica]
[Applauso]
è incredibile no come io abbia potuto
creare questa cosa per voi
sul palco di te dex di cortina tutto in
tempo reale con un computer portatile
con pochissime strumentazioni che sono
una tastiera bluetooth una interfaccia
audio è un software semplicissimo e un
investimento totale di solo mille euro
mi presento il mio nome michele canova
iorfida sono un produttore musicale è la
prima volta che ho incontrato questo
tipo di tecnologia o meglio gli albori
di questa tecnologia fu il 1988 in quel
periodo io frequentavo il conservatorio
cesare pollini di padova praticavo il
violino e personal mio background era
puramente di musica classica
l'unico mio contatto con il mondo
dell'informatica era la mia passione è
un certo minimo di rudimento nei
linguaggi di programmazione dei
videogiochi dell'epoca dei primi un
computer non avrei mai pensato che quel
tipo di tecnologia cambiasse ha voluto
cambiare radicalmente nei successivi 30
anni il mondo della produzione musicale
il mio primo contatto come vi ho detto
fu nell 88 quando a padova un pomeriggio
d'inverno un amico mi mostrò per la
prima volta un campionatore rudimentale
un sintetizzatore è un software di
sequenze musicali
non potevo credere che nella propria
abitazione senza l'utilizzo di molte
persone o senza l'utilizzo di molti
musicisti uno potesse una persona
potesse realizzare una composizione
musicale è fatta e finita
divenne perciò in quel momento chiaro
dentro di me che volevo fare quello
nella vita avrei voluto diventare un
esperto diciamo di questo alla fine
degli anni 80 si comincia a delineare
perciò in qualche modo la
democratizzazione tecnologica applicata
la musica
voglio dire che le dimensioni di
richieste per gli spazi gli spazi
richiesti per gli studi di registrazione
cominciarono a diminuire moltissimo
l'evoluzione delle risorse tecnologiche
cambiavano ripetutamente e sempre in
meglio la possibilità di creare musica e
a questo punto addirittura la forma
canzone stessa cioè la scrittura della
canzone comincio a essere perfettamente
e modificata dalle tecnologie per
capirci torniamo un po indietro e
andiamo verso le lepri origini
chiamiamole così invece di due decenni
dagli anni sessanta agli anni ottanta
come si registrava e come si scrivevano
le canzoni gli spazi dove la musica
veniva registrata erano enormi sale di
ripresa che dovevano servire a contenere
inter e orchestre o intere band musicali
che dovevano registrare prevalentemente
in presa diretta visto le grandissime
limitazioni dei supporti di
registrazione dell'epoca come potete
vedere anche delle immagini le regie
dove il fonico e l'ingegnere del suono
registrava dovevano contenere banchi di
missaggio incredibilmente grandi
tecnologie di registrazione di
preamplificazione valvolare e il
supporto prevalentemente di
registrazione era registratore a nastro
potete vedere che insomma la struttura
della della del registratore ha
veramente grande aveva bisogno di una
stanza solo per questo il nastro che
domina quei due decenni evolve
lentamente da due tecnologie dall'anaci
tecnologia analogica alla tecnologia
digitale
la tecnologia digitale permetterà in
qualche modo di condensare e di rendere
maggiori il numero di strumenti che si
possono registrare sul supporto si passa
negli anni 60 da quattro strumenti
massimo si possono registrare in un
registratore a logico fino alla fine
degli anni 80 col supporto digitale fino
a 48 strumenti contemporaneamente
l'unica caratteristica che continua a
essere uguale per tutti le due
tecnologie sul nastro è la linearità del
processo di registrazione
voglio dire che il nastro ha un inizio e
una fine che segue esattamente l'inizio
e la fine della canzone
voglio dire una canzone fatta di una
strofa di un inciso di una seconda
strofa questo come potete capire bene
l'editing è molto difficile da fare per
abitini intendo cambiare la struttura
della canzone si poteva si fisicamente
tagliare il nastro e rincollare
successivamente ma è una cosa di una
minuzia estrema e non poteva di certo
permettere delle operazioni che in
futuro sarebbero state più facilmente
possibili perciò direi che in quel di
quei due decenni
al centro del processo creativo musicale
c'è sicuramente l'esecuzione del
musicista o della band e che diventano
perciò la parte centrale della creazione
musicale il successivo decennio del
successivo decennio vediamo finalmente
l'affermazione delle digital audio
workstation o di dabliu perciò dei
sistemi delle combinazioni di software e
di hardware che permettono per la prima
volta di digitalizzare di registrare
l'audio in formato digitale su hard disk
questo crea una rivoluzione lenta che
permette perciò di abbattere i limiti di
cui parlavamo prima del formato a nastro
sia analogico e digitale
il numero delle piste il numero degli
strumenti registrabili e in maniera
esponenziale cresce fino arrivare quasi
un numero illimitato e le possibilità di
editing di cui parlavo prima
diventano infinite perché si introduce
un concetto finalmente di non linearità
dove io posso separatamente registrare
una strofa in un secondo momento un
inciso e poi costruire la struttura
della canzone come meglio credo una
figura diventa sempre più importante
all'interno dello studio di
registrazione che è quella del
produttore che grazie a queste nuove
possibilità sia di numero di piste che
di possibilità di editing fa della sua
professione la sua professione diventa
estremamente creativa
tutto ciò contribuisce ulteriormente a
cambiare la scrittura pura della canzone
e ho qui un esempio per voi da farvi
sentire che è di madonna e si chiama don
terni
[Musica]
ora come avete sentito prima di questo
decennio non è la strada è mai stato
possibile tagliare una chitarra editarla
e parla ripetere ossessivamente come è
stato fatto l'inizio di questa canzone
qui capiamo bene che l'arte l'utilizzo
dello strumento di aida buio diventa
anche una forma artistica mi sposto agli
ultimi 20 anni in cui i progressi
tecnologici hanno contribuito a ridurre
ulteriormente gli spazi di registrazione
eliminando totalmente la figura del
banco di messaggio di fronte a noi
il banco viene verrà poi successivamente
virtualizzato all'interno del computer e
quello che si trova di fronte come
potete vedere dalle immagini al al
produttore o al fonico è semplicemente
una serie di monitor di schermi che
agiscano e agiscono prevalentemente da
finestre verso lo studio virtuale come
se noi ci affacciamo verso uno studio
virtuale
qui potete vedere il banco di messaggio
che non è più fisico ma è virtuale
il lader all'interno del software ma non
solo negli ultimi 20 anni un grande
passo in avanti e anche nella
generazione sonora eravamo abituati a
avere strumenti all'interno della nostra
sala di difesa dei pianoforti delle
chitarre o inter orchestre che
registravamo ora come potete vedere il
pianoforte all'interno del software una
batteria disponibili all'interno del
software ma chitarra è disponibile
all'interno del software e addirittura
un'intera orchestra disponibili
all'interno del soft all'interno del
software
il produttore musicale perciò diventa in
qualche modo l'elemento centrale è
l'unico o quasi l'unico elemento umano
all'interno della produzione musicale
degli ultimi 20 anni e la scrittura
della canzone viene ulteriormente
influenzata da questi salti tecnologici
che sono come detto prima la
miniaturizzazione dei componenti
elettronici perciò computer sempre più
potenti
la potenza di calcolo sempre maggiore
che el accesso anche alla nuvola cloud
di librerie musicali che diventano
perciò infinite nello spazio
diciamo nelle dimensioni e aumentano
sempre di più le possibilità produttive
voglio farvi sentire due esempi negli
ultimi 20 anni un produttore giovane
molto bravo che solo
dotato di una cosa veramente molto
simile di un settaggio molto simile a
quello che ho io
si chiama skrillex è affatto questo
brano che è prevalentemente generato
solo da suo alimentano nel computer
[Musica]
[Applauso]
esempio prevalentemente di musica
elettronica voglio farvi anche un
esempio invece più commerciale più che
forse conoscete meglio una canzone di
justin bieber che è stata prodotta
sempre da skrillex e da di plo si chiama
orario now e ve la faccio sentire
[Musica]
bene
certo
un cane
chi punta in questo caso è evidente che
la manipolazione della intonazione e
della ripetizione di questa frase che
siamo all'inizio non sarebbe stata
possibile
vent'anni fa e grazie al processamento
all'interno del computer diventa quasi
un arte diventa una forma creativa la
democratizzazione di cui ho parlato
prima non riguarda poi solo la
produzione musicale ma nell'ultimo
decennio è diventata anche una
democratizzazione dell'accesso alla
musica
non compriamo più i dischi all'interno
di negozi fisici ma accediamo
direttamente a sottoscrizioni ho fatto
l'esempio di spotify ma ce ne sono molte
altre
allo streaming che ci permette e in
qualche modo ci permette di ripercorrere
tutti i passaggi che abbiamo fatto con
la produzione musicale anche per
l'accesso alla musica l'accesso è non
lineare come nella produzione cioè io
posso avere accesso a un database di 10
milioni di canzoni in un secondo senza
che queste canzoni siano virtualmente
occupino dello spazio nel mio hard drive
perché sono in realtà sulla nuvola la
riduzione di costi notevole se pensiamo
che una sottoscrizione a spotify costa
forse la metà di quello che costava un
cd di vent'anni fa non solo la
distribuzione musicale diventa
semplificata anche per l'artista se
pensiamo che un artista al giorno d'oggi
per avere a disposizione un suo brano su
spotify o su un altro servizio di
streaming la blood è molto simile a
molto uguale la procedura di uploadare
un video su youtube perciò di una
semplicità estrema e può essere
disponibile già il giorno dopo
in conclusione quale momento migliore
per creare musica se non oggi gli
innumerevoli strumenti che vi ho fatto
vedere e molti altri sono a disposizione
oggi per esaltare il talento di ragazzi
giovani come skrillex come altri
produttori ventenni che ha a
disposizione un solo portatile riescono
a produrre capolavori della musica
elettronica e non
se pensiamo che oggi un ragazzino di 12
anni di qualsiasi nazionalità nel mondo
armato solo di un portatile può
facilmente competere con un artista
affermato supportato da multinazionali
non vi sembra che mai come in questo
momento la tecnologia liberi le idee
grazie